so many of you are asking Pat if you
were to become the president what are
some policies you would be passing I got
some ideas here to share with you you're
going to think I'm crazy on some of them
one on immigration some of you will lose
your mind when you hear what I want to
do with immigration and a border I got
one with 65 year olds guess what I want
them to work till 70 and you'll find out
why another one is Big Pharma what I
would do with a bunch of different
incentives and one unique program at the
end which I give you some of the numbers
on the last program I want to talk about
anyways again my ideas if you don't like
it debate it in the comment section but
these are my ideas if I were to become
the president all right so let's get
into it if you get value out of this
give it a thumbs up subscribe to the
channel number one my biggest problem is
with our incentive program to me the
compensation structure when you work for
a company a company has a benefits plan
right what they pay you commission
health insurance 401K all that stuff the
tax code is our compensation structure
depending on how they create the comp
plan the tax structure is how the
American people adjust to get the
incentive so first thing I would do is
is stop financially rewarding women
having kids out of wedlock if you want
to have kids out of wedlock there's no
more tax benefits for you there's no
more food stamps there's no more welfare
for you I know you're not going to like
it I'm not going to incentivize that
because that's not good for the US
economy we need fathers and households
we need moms and dads to be together
proven statistically it's better for
kids it's safer for kids better for the
economy so the incentives will be for
that so what does this mean if you have
three or more kids per year we're going
to give you tax incentive every year
only if you're married to the same wife
you guys have three kids together after
the third one there's a tax incentive
will give you for the 18 years of this
kid being raised by you so if you do
three tax incentives four tax incentive
five tax incentive only if you're
married father and mother raising that
kid that's one tax incentive number two
65 year olds need to start working till
70. Pat that's insane you're not going
to get something like that to pass
listen we're running out of money 65
year Social Security we need you to go
back five years that's pathetic that'll
never pass here's a caveat you ready for
every penny you make up to 250 000 after
you turn 65 you pay zero in taxes wait
what let me explain so you make two
hundred thousand dollars he has a 65
year old you pay 50 in taxes what are
you keeping only a hundred thousand
dollars now you have to make a decision
with your wife if I retire at 65 I'm
leaving how much money on the table babe
if you work this year and you make two
hundred thousand dollars you're going to
keep 100 of it you're not going to pay
the other 100 taxes why don't you work
one more year you work one more year oh
my god did you see how much money are we
having it back yeah go one more your big
take care of your health go one more
year babe five years later you got a
million bucks wow that's crazy exactly
then if you want to go one more year
it's up to you we're living longer now
but guess what that does to us we don't
need to tap into Social Security because
it is simply running out here's the next
thing that's not going to be popular you
know how much money we're spending on
entitlement programs and Welfare and all
that stuff 53 percent of our federal
expenditures being spent on entitlement
programs and Welfare by the way here's
what I would do every year I would
reduce entitlement programs by seven
percent every year so whatever our
budget is if it's three trillion dollars
you're one 210 billion dollars lower
your two 200 billion dollars lower your
395 billion dollars lower it keeps going
lower and lower and lower by the 10th
year entitlement program splits in half
Rule of 72 we would decrease our
entitlement program by seven percent
every year for 10 years it would be very
popular for the workers that are making
the economy work it would not be very
popular for those who rely on these
entitlement programs here's the next
thing on entitlement programs that's not
fair Pat how could you say you're going
to cut these entitlement programs out
some of these people are relying on that
two thousand dollars a month no problem
guess what for those that still get the
two thousand dollars or three thousand
dollars a month I would divide that
exactly on what's the most money they've
ever made in a month on average over a
10-year period if that equal waste to 30
hours a week you will need to work for
the government 30 hours a week I'm not
giving you money for free why are we
giving money away for free taxpayers
money who are working we're taking from
them and giving them people saying stay
home and we're still going to take care
of them no no go work 30 hours a week
answering phone calls go work 30 hours a
week cleaning some of the freeways go
work 30 hours a week no problem and by
the way those who receive entitlement
programs will have drug testing going on
surprise they used to do the military
all the time it was great simply they
would get up and said if you're Social
Security the last four starts with the
number four step up and you would step
up let's go we're going to test you this
month for XYZ we would do random drug
tests quarterly for people that take
entitlement programs to make sure you're
not using drugs because we're concerned
for you and uh why are we giving that
money away that's got to be an
investment so people get off of welfare
and entitlement that's not to give money
just to give it for the hell of it I'm
sure if you're still watching this
you're sitting there saying Pat's trying
to make friends with all these ideas
it's your wonderful ideas right some
people are probably losing their minds
going on Twitter screw you pbd I totally
get it I told you my ideas here's the
next idea big Pharma there's 100 95
countries in the world okay give or take
only two countries allow for big Pharma
to advertise on TV one is New Zealand
the other one is U.S or we follow New
Zealand's lead since when in the world
does anybody follow New Zealand what are
we doing now the day I get elected
remember I'm not born in U.S so things
have to change but if I were to get
elected we're going to have to stop big
Pharma advertising on TV you actually
need to get to work and go meet with
doctors and sell them why your drug is
good no longer advertising on television
day one first executive order big Pharma
is done advertising on television by the
way don't you think these big Pharma
people are so happy a guy like me could
never run you know how much money that
would cost them a lot of money so
they're in a safe place right now
because I can't run staying on big
Pharma one of the challenges I think we
have is the the amount of patent these
pharmaceutical companies have to sell a
drug that takes them 10 cents to make 25
cents to make they're selling it for 200
dollars because they can't so they keep
the pattern and they do that for 20
years then great lawyers and lobbyists
extend another 18 years on the patent so
that thing stays expensive and the
consumer the individual that needs that
medicine whatever it could be doesn't
get it because they can't afford to pay
for it I would create a structure to
incentivize the company that came up
with the patent to sell it to others so
they can make more money for their
competitors to also sell it but we would
ask them to have a structure where the
price would be lower where they don't
have to charge it a thousand ten
thousand percent above what it really
costs them due to it and on top of that
we would work on lengthening shortening
the length of patents in America instead
of 20 years we would shorten it the next
one would be education I got a big
problem with what they're doing in
public schools right now where some
parents are cornered who can't afford to
put their kids into private school I
would incentivize private schools in
America who are not grooming who are not
indoctrinating the kids there will be an
incentive for private schools to compete
with public schools so this the most
powerful you Union America which is this
teachers union that we have attended got
three million there's like a couple of
them but the biggest one is three
million members we need to compete
against them so one of the first things
we would do is incentivize more private
schools to be started I would ask
entrepreneurs and many of these wealthy
folks if you're not going to run for
office if you're not going to go work in
church if you're not going to work in
non-profit use your billions and tens of
millions to start some private schools
we would incentivize you to do that
based on certain structures that teaches
the values and principles that this
great country America was founded on
immigration so this one's going to piss
a lot of people off 1984 my parents
while we're living in Iran Wars going on
it's ugly Iraq the whole thing is taking
place we're in Tehran we applied for
green card we never got our green card
while we were in the Iran we escaped one
to Germany at a refugee camp year and a
half later I remember when we got the
Green Card got on a plane came here
November 28 1990 we waited 6.5 half
years for our green card it was such a
special day I can't even describe it to
you one of the greatest days of my life
was that day the other day was June 20th
of 1999 when I got out of the army held
my hand up and I became a U.S citizen
great things are worth waiting for we
would freeze the border and any
immigration for one year suspend all
immigration for one year zero
immigration coming for one year until
everybody on both sides figures it out
to realize priorities people that live
in America first
then we go everybody that's everywhere
else we'll come to you but number one is
we got to take care of our families
first that'll Force other countries who
are around our borders such as Mexico
and other places to get their country to
become better so people are not running
away from you to come to us that's what
we'll do one year suspension of
immigration with the border and I know a
lot of people are not going to be happy
about that housing uh would be another
issue right now we don't have a lot of
homes that people can afford to buy so
we need more starter homes everybody's
trying to build the stuff that we can
make a lot of money with boom builders
that build things houses under four
hundred thousand dollars some states may
be different because it's obviously by
ZIP code and by state but to give you an
example under four hundred thousand
dollars if the Builder is willing to
build it they pay zero percent taxes on
those properties because we need more
homes start at home specifically for the
younger generation they cannot afford to
buy a house right now so two things here
one is military and the other one is
business they both same thing is
happening with them so in business
you're noticing a lot of companies are
consolidating right these big banks are
getting bigger right because they're
buying up everyone body or Walmart
Amazon they're getting bigger because
they're gobbling up small little markets
that have been there in a small little
town for 50 years they say we're going
to raise the minimum wage those guys can
do it Walmart can do what Amazon can do
it these guys can do it will create
incentives for small business owners
because at one point we had half of
America work for small businesses more
and more and more is becoming big
companies this is why some of these
politicians that get up acting like
they're for the small person they're
helping out the bigger company the
bigger company can afford to pay higher
prices for their employees it's the
small ones that can't once we lose them
forget about competition the military
side in 1990 they came out with the
Congress came out with some a law that
they pushed all these 51 different
military contractors that we had that
people were at least buying they were
competing against each other they took
the 51 and they Consolidated it all down
to five companies that we have today
military that's not competition they're
all best friends they don't make a lot
of money they all get the contracts they
all love more war they make more money
when there's war and conflicts and they
things like that we're going to
incentivize companies to break apart and
small businesses to be created here to
compete against them incentives or
companies to not fear going up against
these guys last one will be a massive
campaign we would launch called the hero
making machine turning the right people
into Heroes not complainers not whiners
those that life is hard but they step up
and they lead their families whether
it's mothers that are leading their kids
after the father died that's a hero
she's got three jobs I want to turn her
into a hero whether it's the kid that's
creating a business on the site to make
money to help out family because
families going through challenging times
that's a hero whether it's a cop that
saved two three kids took a bullet and
we don't recognize those cops we're
going to turn them into Heroes if it's
the small business owner that risked
everything him and his wife all their
savings they sold their house they sold
their cars they started a business and
created 100 jobs in the community after
three years we want to turn them into
Heroes it'll be a program we'll launch
also called the 180 Pro program the 180
Program will recognize people that made
the biggest 180 in their lifetime used
to be a drug addict and a drug dealer
changed his life gave his life to God
when I worked at a company is now a
c-suite executive making two temporary
years happily married got three kids ten
years ago he was in jail the 180 Program
let's turn that guy into a hero 180
Program could be you were a regular
person complaining bitching whining
blaming everybody you chose to stand up
for yourself become a leader now you're
running a business you got 38 employees
in Kansas we're going to turn that
person into Hero part of the 180 Program
on top of the hero making machine and
the 180 Program we will launch the
national book club yes National book
club let me give you some stats on books
when you look at numbers families making
over seventy five thousand dollars a
year versus families making under thirty
thousand dollars per year here's what
you'll notice adults with annual
household incomes of thirty thousand
dollars or less are more than twice as
likely to be non-book readers as the
most affluent adults about 17 of those
making over seventy five thousand
dollars per year did not read books
while 36 percent of those is making less
than thirty thousand dollars per year
this is according to CNBC Meeting those
making over 75 they read books twice as
much as those under thirty thousand why
if you read books I'm free because of
books I'm a 1.8 GPA kid in high school
who was great at math but I never read
any book first time I finished the book
cover to cover I got out of the army I
worked at valleys my sister recommended
me how to win friends and influence
people and my boss Robbie recommend me
how to master the art of selling then I
read 2 000 books of my life change we
will launch a monthly National book club
and you post your book reviews on
Twitter different places and the books
could be categories Finance it could be
fiction it could be non-fiction it could
be money it could be so many different
things related to you improving yourself
that will pick and choose the best book
reviews you post a one minute video and
white house will retweet those and turn
you into hero because God knows in
America we need more book readers we're
too distracted right now with social
media we got to get our heads like this
instead of like this that's what we got
to do that's what we would be doing 180
program Euro making machine a national
book club if you've got value out of
this video give it a thumbs up subscribe
to the channel and by the way I'm
curious what are some of the policies
crazy policies you would come out with
if you were the president tweet at me
right here this is my handle at Patrick
with David I want to hear from you and
on top of that if you've never seen the
video we did on big Pharma click here to
watch that video it's fascinating take
care everybody bye bye
foreign
[Music]